What if one day everyone on nurse pulled their forks away from the stakes and
turn Vegan,
whether for the sake of a healthier lifestyle to alleviate animal suffering or
to fight global warming,
everyone found their own reason to say no to a juicy burger,
a fluffy omelet or a cheesy pizza.
Even ice cream would make the no,
no list.
What a Vegan diet save the planet from climate change?
Would this improve your health?
What would happen to all those cattle?
This is what f and here's what would happen if everyone in the world became
Vegan.
There are 20 million vegans in the u s alone six times more than there were in
2015 tofu was filling in for me on restaurant menus.
Dairy free milk alternatives are pushing their way on the supermarket shelves.
What was once a radical diet choice is becoming mainstream?
Did you know food produced by animals is responsible for a quarter of all
greenhouse gas emissions.
Most of that comes from cows.
Every year the world's cattle population leaves a carbon footprint equivalent to
the CEO to emissions of every car,
train,
ship,
and aircraft in the world.
Put together.
Wait,
how exactly does livestock contribute to global warming?
There's about a billion and a half cows in the world.
Each cow releases up to 120 kilograms of methane per year on the climate change
scale.
Methane's negative effect is 23 times higher than carbon dioxide's.
On top of that,
cattle take as much as two thirds of all agricultural land on the planet.
If we all went Vegan,
we'd use most of that pasture land for restoring forests and grasslands to help
reduce carbon dioxide in the air.
We start growing more crops to fill the gaps in our food supply.
Livestock related gas emissions would drop by 70% but what would happen?
All those farm animals with no demand for grilled chicken and roast beef,
billions of animals would be slaughtered or abandoned.
Some animals like sheep and pigs might be able to return to the wild,
but their numbers would drop due to predators.
Others though,
like broiler chickens couldn't survive in the wild,
is they're so far removed from their ancestors,
they wouldn't know what to do.
Their best chance might be in sanctuaries where they'd be taken care of until
they die out.
Your local butcher would have to find another job,
and so with millions of farmers,
they can start growing more crops or restoring forests,
but on a large scale,
rural communities they used to supply you with milk,
eggs and meat would face significant unemployment.
Developing countries who built their lives and trades around livestock would
deal with major economic disruption,
but everyone would be a little bit healthier or Woodway.
Adopting a Vegan diet,
it doesn't automatically make you a healthy eater.
Vegans often miss out on vital nutrients.
They often don't get enough calcium,
iron,
vitamin D,
zinc,
vitamin B,
12 or omega three fatty acids.
Since meat,
eggs and cheese would no longer be served as a perfect source of protein.
You'd have to eat lot of beans,
soy and lentils,
but with a proper diet,
we'd suffer from less coronary heart disease,
stroke,
and diabetes.
Global mortality rates would drop by up to 10% this would mean 8 million less
deaths per year and up to $1 trillion saved on healthcare and last working days
annually.
But not in developing countries.
We're over 2 billion people already faced massive under nourishment without
meat.
For them,
things wouldn't get healthier.
They'd get worse.
Having the entire world go vegan might be a little extreme,
but keeping food's produced by animals and our diet means we will eventually
have to deal with the gas emissions.
Luckily for those hooked on me,
clean solutions to reduce emissions from the livestock industry already exist.
All that's left is to implement them.
What about you,
would you say no to your meatball?
Pass it tonight.